hello and welcome to the special edition
of spectator tv i'm katie balls and i'm
joined by james forsythe
and we've just had the fourth ballot of
the tory leadership contest when it
comes to the parliamentary rounds and
the results were that kerry badenock has
been knocked out she won 59 votes which
put her in fourth place so she has left
the contest
um in third place was liz trust on 86
votes and second was penny morgan on 92
votes and in first place was rushing on
118 which
the 120 they were guaranteed to your
place in the final two now we only have
to wait till tomorrow afternoon to find
out the final results of which she will
go to the membership but to discuss what
we currently know and what to expect in
the next 24 hours and beyond um i will
now turn to james james what struck you
most about those results
so liz trust is now in the single digits
of penny morton six votes away and she
will be i think fairly confident that
she can pick up considerably more of
kevin badenock's vote
than uh penny morton cancer i mean liz
trusts his chances of making the final
two
have increased quite significantly after
i think what was it what was generally
regarded as a disappointing result for
her
last night
uh i think the other thing that strikes
me is
that you know kate madden is out and as
you you've called this from the start of
this contest she has been kind of the
breakout star of the race uh she is
someone who has gone from a junior
ministerial role to still being in this
race when uh cabinet ministers are out
of it um and i think it's also
particularly impressive because she
stood her campaign up in in a matter of
days you know there are there are some
other people uh if you think of you know
i think it was no surprise to anyone in
westminster when tom tokenheart ran or
penny mordent ran but you know kevin
knock you know only anyone was expecting
her to run she's been a surprise figure
in this race
and she has had a remarkably successful
run to get this far
now liz trusted supporters have you know
called on camera not now for days now to
drop out drop out allow those trusts to
unite the right the question now i
suppose is how much ill will is there
from those calls on her from her and her
sports from those calls for her to drop
out and how successfully can those trust
do that
my my guess is she will do it
successfully enough to make it onto that
ballot paper now let's go straight away
to a few questions and do you send them
in and we also have discussion points
for one another
and which is
ultimately here's what speaking of kevin
baden off we have a question from gp
which is what's kemi baillout's future
in the party
james it seems like a safe bet that she
is going to be promoted to cabinet role
after this no yeah i mean i think it is
i also think you know i felt throughout
this contest and then you you said very
similar katie that you know if this
contest was taking place with the tories
out of power she would have
she would have won because you know with
she there has been a kind of david
cameron-like qualities for campaign and
with those five years in opposition
that would have given her i think enough
enough time for people to feel that she
was ready i think that i think the
obstacle to kevin babnock was you know
could you really imagine her six weeks
from now walking through the black door
at number 10 and having to be prime
minister but she has clearly established
herself as a major figure in the party
and someone who is
hugely popular with the volunteer party
too
now following on for that question from
martin which is who will michael
governor support now of course michael
gove was one of kenny bailey not early
backers
and at the time when michael go came out
for kevin baibenlock i think there was
some surprise in certain quarters given
the michael graves such an experienced
minister his endorsement being very
helpful to different campaigns
and there's also some conspiracies so
there are figures who i think steve
baker vocalized it but there were lots
of mps saying this in fact they thought
kerry baden was a michael gove plant and
it was a way to split the right and
therefore that eventually folded behind
rishi soon ag so what's your money on in
terms of what michael gove will do next
do you think he's going to come out and
formally endorse another candidate do
you think he's going to stay quiet do
you think he's going to stare
from the sidelines i think trying to
predict what michael gove will do in a
leadership contest as someone who had
written the whole cover story on the uh
boris go campaign
only for only for it to be exploded in
2016 or on the thursday morning uh it is
a hard thing to do i'm
clearly right that that it was when
michael gove her secretary of state came
out and said i've been carried out not
to be prime minister it made her
candidate see
instantly more serious that someone with
his governing experience was saying
actually this person who works for me in
my department is the best choice gave it
a real boost and that and also
particular i think within the dynamics
of this race particularly because that
stood in contrast to
uh the criticisms that anne marie
trevelli and penny morgan's boss was was
making of her um yeah previously in
private and then and then yesterday and
in public as he is
what he describes as a drive-by um and
so i think we wait to see what michael
gove does i don't think i mean you know
michael graves is rarely predictable i
mean he knows all the remaining three
candidates well um liz ross was one of
his junior ministers when he was
education they are the two
longer-serving cabinet ministers um uh
yeah he obviously worked which you see
that closely and penny morgan was the
junior minister of his at the capitol
office and michael cohen who didn't
touch this trust i mean they're often at
different ends of the argument really
aren't they
are the arguments over trade deals
australian trade deals i mean there are
some who say that michael gove is in the
what trust's team or her supporters
describe as the axis of evil
yeah but there's always been a funny um
from her uh her defense of wood-burning
goats that she put it um
there's always been a kind of funny
friendship between them despite their
ideological differences so i i wouldn't
rule anything out one to watch
um now uh
why did rishi cena pick up so few votes
so if we look at the exact figures uh
rishi sunuk um as we point out so he won
115 votes in the third ballot so that
was yesterday and today he was on 118
votes now the reason that is quite
surprising is that he only gained three
votes and given it was tom teugenhart's
supporters who were out to get i think
there was a sense that he would find it
easier to take from those but
inside of how confusing this contest was
he made quite a big jump between the
second and the third rounds from 101 to
115 and that's when it was throughout
the braverman's supporters who were
technically up for grabs so james
do you think it's not as simple as
people
we're not necessarily just seeing the
supporters of the campus falling out
moving there could be more going on i
think one of the things that is very
interesting is how all the candidates
are quite their number of publicly
declared supporters is quite far below
the vote shares they're getting
which is strange you would think that by
this point if you were voting people you
would be declaring
i mean i think what hurt rishi sooner in
this round was a sense that all the
action was elsewhere on the ballot
and i think that means that you know
that that that that causes you a problem
in a contest that people feel but you
know oh that that that that that that
very close yeah there weren't that many
votes separating second third and fourth
that sense that that's where the action
was you know once um one came out not
supported just messaged me saying they
think that what happened was that they
lost some to liz so while they gained
some from tom they did they were
squeezed down by the trust campaign he
basically said to people look
um if you don't come round the right is
not going to have the right and the most
commons is not going to have a candidate
in the final two because uh penny will
be so far ahead of liz so
i mean there are all sorts of things
going on here um i think the one thing
learning
what i would say is with relative
certainty is i don't think any camp is
in a position to be trying to kind of
manipulate things by moving votes here
and moving back there
i think it's much more but you've got
these kind of independent cross currents
of you know people want to bolster this
person or bolster that person or i think
that and i think it is an interesting
question we're here but did some
uh people who were backing him about not
suddenly think oh well i don't think
she's gonna make the final two but i
don't want it to be a rush to see that
penny boarding contest
sorry
okay so then uh james effectively right
now we have a situation where actually
it it's feasible that you could have any
of the current three as a final two
penny will invested this trust it's
possible british steel is not at 120 yet
and again penny morden could still uh
come out triumphant um but it does feel
as though this trust is gaining momentum
and receiving only a little bit to go
over over the line now looking at some
of the other questions i mean there's a
lot of disappointment in the chat when
it comes to
um when it comes to uh the fact that
kerry vadenk has been knocked out
uh
looking at some of the grassroots
polling effectively there's a you got
paul today suggesting kemi baden would
beat every group
when it comes to um
well any candidate when it came to the
final two so do you think there could be
a bit of a backlash to the fact that mps
have chosen not to put her in the final
two despite all the polling in recent
days suggesting that the the membership
did want her there well i think that the
easiest way to set out an event at tory
party conference in october would be to
put kenny badnock on the panel um she is
clearly hugely popular
i think there will be disappointing
members that she has not reached that
final round
uh one sport of liz trust was arguing to
me yesterday but you know it was the
mp's job to knock kevin knockout because
you know she didn't have enough
experience to be prime minister and so
she shouldn't be put in front of the
members i'm not sure that all the
members will buy that argument they
would like to make that decision for
themselves i suspect
but i think that the question now is
where does that bad knock vote go
how much of it you discuss this
endlessly how much
of her vote in terms of mps can she
transfer if she chooses to endorse
anyone which is cersei and also if she
chooses to back someone
does that candidate benefit from the
energy
enthusiasm that she has generated in
this contest
and we will be back with all the twists
and turns in there i think at this point
we're going to leave it there so do you
join us for the next one of these when
it comes to the leadership contest and
with that thank you to james and thank
you to max our producer we look forward
to seeing you again